there were a number of days over a
period of 20 months when Gatherings took
place in Downing Street that went past
the point where they could be said to be
necessary for work purposes that was
wrong I bitterly regret it I understand
public anger and I continue to apologize
for what happened on my watch and I take
full responsibility but as you've just
said chair the purpose of this inquiry
is not to reopen so-called party gate it
is to discover whether or not I lied to
Parliament wittingly misled colleagues
and the country about what I knew and
believed about those Gatherings when I
said that the rules and the guidance had
been followed at number 10.
I'm here to say to you hand on heart
that I did not lie to the house when
those statements were made they were
made in good faith and on the basis of
what I honestly knew and believed at the
time